one of the things you'll get with I see  you and your family and friends at the  Cimarron Rose community center on Ann  Road between Buffalo and Durango I have  the honor of being a guest conductor for  their Polar Express Rye they got an  amazing stat they got dancers there what  they do is they take their Outdoor  Sports courts and they built this thing  that's supposed to look like a Polar  Express train but you're really not  going anywhere you just sit at these  seats and you have a great singing and  dancing by the young people uh caroling  hot cocoa and cookies it starts at six  tickets are still available five dollars  today seven dollars at the door tomorrow  they did one last night they're doing  one tonight and I'll be there tomorrow  night Heather lots of fun things going  on this weekend here in the valley